the miami grand prix is this weekend and
i'm catching up with mclaren formula one
driver daniel ricardo who knows how to
rev our engines
i want to talk about how what it takes
to get into tip-top shape for you
because this is a high adrenaline career
that you've got going on i would say
like five days a week just like strength
and stuff uh and then where the races
are like 90 minutes long so we're doing
a lot of like cardio training endurance
uh it's kind of like broad you just do
everything
the pictures of you with your human
backpack oh yeah you know who i'm
talking about that little man is so cute
your nephew right thank you yeah oh my
gosh is he cheering you on at home does
he love watching you race yeah he's like
my biggest fan does he have a little
need for speed do you think in his
future i already got him a little
go-kart you did not
the miami grand prix is here in town how
are you feeling i feel good very quickly
became my favorite race of the year yeah
other than my home one in australia but
i do love it and i'm excited to have
another one daniel is known for his
smile his love of jokes and his need for
speed but priority for this mclaren f1
driver is safety that's why we teamed up
with daniel and heineken for their when
you drive never drink initiative in
formula one it's as much as
we love like risking it and pushing it
to the edge we still care a lot about
safety and when people do drink
confidence goes up and yeah they can
probably think they're an f1 driver so
they can travel exactly exactly so it's
encouraging them to be a passenger and
not get behind the wheel and it's so
easy to call an uber
this weekend heineken's doing something
really cool so if you uber the code
great rides you can get home safely all
weekend with a discounted code from
heineken and that's encouraging people
as well to uh when they drive and have a
drink
i think i'm just going to roll on out of
here with this mclaren here
i left the keys inside perfect have you
been drinking no all right it's all
yours
bye y'all
[Music]
you